who is Aquaman if you've seen Justice
League you know him as the ludicrously
muscular Jason Momoa if you grew up
watching Superfriends you remember him
as the blond guy in an orange shirt who
didn't usually have much to do
if you've encountered internet humor in
the past 20 years you've probably heard
that he talks to fish that's not
although he's been a king a husband a
father and amputee and an exile in his
decades-long existence so he's a pretty
busy fish guy here is the untold truth
of Aquaman alternate origins everybody
knows that Aquaman's from Atlantis but
in his first appearance in 1940 ones
more fun Comics number 73 that wasn't
the case at all his father was a
world-famous undersea Explorer and
researcher Aquaman's mother died when he
was a baby and his father took him to
live under the sea using the ancient
science of that forgotten civilization
he raised Aquaman to live comfortably
under the sea giving him the ability to
breathe water in the name Aquaman
it was only later stories that made
Aquaman and Atlantean Prince in the
1940s he was simply too busy fighting
Nazi u-boat captains to have that
complex a backstory alternate alternate
origins adventure Comics number 260
established that Aquaman was the son of
a lighthouse keeper named Tom curry and
a mysterious woman who came from the sea
on her deathbed she revealed herself as
an exile from Atlantis and that their
son Arthur had inherited her aquatic
powers later stories would establish the
mysterious woman as the princess of
Atlantis making Arthur curry the heir to
its throne in 1989 Aquaman's special
number 1 this origin was revised yet
again so that Aquaman was born in
Atlantis left to die in the open ocean
as an infant and later adopted by the
lighthouse keeper Arthur being raised by
a lighthouse keeper has remained one of
the more consistent details of Aquaman's
origin stories going back to the
beginning even when later retcons would
add in a biological father who is an
undersea wizard and other familial
weirdness
Aquaman and his octo pal most people
remember Aquaman's sidekick as Aqualad a
dark-haired teen in red and blue
a teenage Ally Aqualad guards and
defends all that lives
aqualad first appeared in 1960 but
aquaman met his first lasting ally years
earlier in 1956 in adventure comics
number 229 Aquaman is inspired by a
Canadian Mounties relationship with his
horse so he holds a contest to see which
sea creatures should become a sidekick
the winner ends up being an octopus
named topo since Aquaman solo adventures
pretty much all take place at sea an
octopus has more to contribute than you
might expect
even after Aqualad came on the scene in
adventure comics number 269 that clever
octopus had stuck around as a member of
the supporting cast
Aquaman uncovered you've almost
certainly seen the cover to The Brave
and the bold number 28 the first
appearance of the Justice League of
America now here's what you might not
know that first Justice League cover
where they're fighting Starro is the
first time Aquaman ever appeared on a
comic book cover sure Aquaman had been
around for 19 years but he'd never had
his own comic Superboy had been the
cover feature on adventure comics for as
long as he and Aquaman had been featured
in the book before that Aquaman was
overshadowed by Green Arrow in the pages
of more fun comics being a minor hero
whose adventures were mostly at sea
Aquaman had never joined the Justice
Society of America
DC's first super team by the time that
team was revamped with a new name
however Aquaman had survived for so long
that his veteran status made him a show
in for the new team making him an active
part of the DC Universe increased his
popularity to the degree that he finally
got his own solo comic starting in 1962
aqua married having his own title in the
1960s gave Aquaman more room to build a
complete supporting cast including an
ongoing love interest something he'd
never had before Mira was introduced in
Aquaman number 11 as a beautiful Queen
from another dimension with the ability
to control water an issue 18 Aquaman
finally takes the throne of Atlantis but
learns that he must immediately choose a
queen so he and mera get married in that
same issue superhero weddings were
largely unheard of when this happened in
1964 the most famous superhero wedding
of the 1960s was mr. fantastic in the
invisible girl time and not in Fantastic
Four but that didn't happen until 1965 a
year after the big aqua wedding Aquaman
established the tropes that would turn
up again and Fantastic Four and other
wedding stories like costume guest stars
as gasps
and of course supervillain attacks baby
on board once Aquaman and Queen Mira
were married it was only a matter of
time before they produced an heir
Arthur curry jr. usually called aqua
baby was born in Aquaman number 23 in
the 1960s Aquaman was breaking new
ground just by settling down and
starting a family of course he was also
one of the only superheroes who ruled
his own kingdom
Aquaman had always stood apart from
other heroes due to the aquatic nature
of his adventures so it made sense for
his stories to evolve along their own
paths instead of following the usual
superhero tropes but by the 1970s
Aquaman's idyllic undersea life would be
coming to an end in adventure comics
number 452 Aquaman has a showdown with
his greatest villain Black Manta who is
kidnapped aqua baby and put him in a
slow-moving deathtrap that baby's a
goner
unless Aquaman and Aqualad fight to the
death Black Manta now that's not very
neighborly it's fairly standard
supervillain fare and it seems like
Aquaman will get everyone out alive like
usual unfortunately it doesn't go that
way this time Aquaman disrupts black
mantas plans but it's too late Arthur
curry jr. is already gone when they get
him out of the suffocating bubble
ever since Aquaman's son died his
adventures have taken on a darker tone
and his character has had a more
brooding attitude give him a hand
Aquaman would be reimagined again in the
1990s he already had grown long hair and
a beard and was soon one hand lighter
after a villain shoved him into a pool
of carnivorous fish that were
conveniently immune to Aquaman's
telepathy he replaced his hand with the
hooked end of a harpoon and soon
abandoned his famous orange shirt it's
been me the next few years in a gray
armoured half shirt and gray in green
pants by 2003 the aesthetic of 90s
Arthur curry already felt tied to that
decade and it was time to move on a new
creative team finally gave the hero a
shave and haircut as well as a new left
hand this hand was made of water created
by the magic of the Lady of the lake a
magical being better known for helping
out a different King Arthur back to
basics one of Aquaman's better known
incarnations was as a regular guest star
on Batman The Brave and the bold voiced
by John DiMaggio this version of Arthur
curry is bombastic loud and brash
he's supremely confident in his
abilities as a hero and adventurer and
not shy about sharing his confidence
unlike other version
of Aquaman who were often moody and
bitter brave in the balls Aquaman is
endlessly upbeat and fun you were
magnificent yes big hug interestingly
the Aquaman of the 2017 Justice League
film played by Jason Momoa has a bit of
brave in the bulldog oh man to him he's
a more serious character but he also has
the brash confidence in daredevil
attitude that made his animated
counterparts such a success mixing the
masculine charisma of Jason Momoa with
the classic outsider perspective Aquaman
has always had turned out to be a smash
success and the character was a standout
in Justice League we'll have to see if
the upcoming solo Aquaman movie will
manage to continue the characters
watering winning streak